uh speaking of violence we haven't done
this for a while and
and i think it's important to do it
again
did you know that there were 10 mass
shootings this past weekend
just this past weekend that finished a
couple days ago um
the gun violence archive tracks mass
shootings
and on june 4th 5th and 6th there were
10
individual shooting incidents in which a
minimum
of four victims were shot
either injured or killed not including
any shooter who may have also been
injured or killed
during the incident this is ten
incidents
where at least four people were killed
and or
injured and consider for a second by
this definition of mass shooting where
you need at least
four injuries or deaths there were a
whole bunch of other incidents with
two or three people being injured and
killed
when the baseline is set at four
injured and killed we had 10
such incidents this past weekend and it
barely made news
it is just another normal weekend in the
united states of america
some examples in portland oregon four
were killed
and one were injured at a home in
indianapolis indiana
two were killed and two were injured all
in the parking lot
of a boston market restaurant in north
carolina
four people were shot and injured at a
party
at a trailer park and i could go through
and give you
all of the various stories but you can
imagine
how all of these or many of these went
down
but 10 mass shootings this weekend and
it barely makes news
because it has become background noise
that's the tragic reality of the
situation
the the loss of life the injury that's
one tragedy
the other tragedy is that this stuff
barely even makes the news anymore ah
another weekend
another 10 mass shootings and the number
is probably more like 25 if you include
those where
two or three people were injured as well
also
it's embarrassing it's not just tragic
it's embarrassing the world looks at us
clearly we have the resources for
dealing with this it's not a money issue
we have no shortage of ideas for how to
deal with it even if
you know without touching the second
amendment which we have a second
amendment okay
without even going close to infringing
on the second amendment
we have so many ideas for things that
should be done look at what happened
on vaccines once we got competent
leadership in power in january we
clearly can do things
we clearly can manage big projects
there's no it's not an impossibility
and yet there is simply no political
will
to deal with this and it's a global
embarrassment truly
and you know even if you don't care
about gun violence per
se like maybe you don't do you realize
how this makes us look to our
adversaries
and the ideas that this gives our
adversaries they
see another weekend another 10 mass
shootings what the hell is wrong with
these americans
if the you they are saying if the u.s
population has been propagandized enough
that they won't do anything on guns if
they can't even pass
100 universal background checks uh
when when democrats control the house
senate white house and right after this
the sandy hook shooting if they can't do
that
clearly these are very manipulatable
people
this is one of those situations where
the world sees the insanity of this
is this not yet affecting the right
people
and that's why nothing is being done is
the combination
of the gun profit lobby because that's
what they are and the gun nuts is that
combination too powerful
to allow anything to be done my issue
isn't even with the firearms
necessarily but it's with american gun
culture
lack of screening lack of enforcement of
laws
lack of of ongoing training
insurance policies if you own guns lack
of access to mental health
treatment the political movement that
fetishizes guns yeah okay the guns are a
problem but what i mean is
it doesn't have to be a problem of guns
necessarily
and i'm being careful with the wording
here in our case it is a problem of guns
but also of all of those other things
that i mentioned
and the world sees it and it's
humiliating it's tragic
it's embarrassing and there is no i mean
i wish i had any optimism
i i have no optimism you know okay biden
announced some stuff they're going to be
he is directing the creation of certain
groups to look at okay
it was an effort but most of that is
just hey please look into this type
stuff
i am not optimistic on this issue at all
if you are
let me know why let me know why i should
be more optimistic you can find me on
twitter
at deepakman for the longest time
i was having trouble finding snacks that
are healthy but actually taste great
and fill me up and satisfy a craving
and that's why it's great that i
stumbled upon monk pack
and we asked them to be one of our
sponsors monk pack
keto nut and seed bars are delicious
snacks that have one gram of sugar or
less
only two to three grams of net carbs and
just 150 calories perfect for a
keto or low carb diet or anybody who
like me
just prefers to eat a low sugar diet i
love the monk pack keto nut and seed
bars
because it's really just a great balance
of sweet and salty soft and chewy
but with a nice crunch from the nuts and
seeds flavors include
caramel or caramel you tell me sea salt
sea salt dark chocolate and peanut
butter dark chocolate that's my favorite
they'll give you all of your money back
if you don't love it go to monkpack.com
the link is down below
and they'll give you twenty percent off
any of their products when you use
coupon code pacman